Christian dö der Vorsitzende der FDP
Fraktion unter anderem zum konspirativen
Treffen in potzam und offenbar sind es
ja auch mehrere gewesen an dem unter
anderem auch AFD Politiker beteiligt
gewesen sind unter anderem ein enger
Mitarbeiter von Alis Weidel der
mittlerweile seines Postens enthoben
wurde weil man sich dann offenbar doch
ein wenig davon distanzieren will von
dem ganzen Vorsatz von dem ganzen
Vorgang führende juristische
Organisationen haben gestern die
Veranstaltung aufs schärfste kritisiert
unter anderem der Deutsche Richterbund
aber auch der deutsche Anwaltsverein und
der Deutsche juristinenbund sowie drei
weitere Organisation sie haben von einer
schauerlichen Vision gesprochen von
einem Angriff auf Verfassung und
liberalen Rechtsstaat und haben von
einem Vorhaben gesprochen dass mit allen
juristischen und politischen Mitteln
verhindert werden muss Alis Weidel sieht
die Sache ein wenig
anders
die
Unterstellung
des linken
Aktivisten Netzwerkes
Korrektiv und die ungeprüfte
Weiterverbreitung und
Instrumentalisierung von
Korrektiv und die
Instrumentalisierung und die
Weiterverbreitung der unwahren
Behauptung und unwahren
Unterstellungen Stellen einer der
größten
ungeheuerlichsten Medien und
politikskandale der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland da sehr verehrte Damen und
Herren das sind DDR
Methoden es handelte sich
nicht um ein AFD treffen ich find super
dass sie das alles jetzt ganz genau
mitschreiben sondern um eine private
Begegnung von persönlich mit
unterschiedlichem Hintergrund so auch
AFD Politikern und CDU Politikern und
Menschen ohne
Parteibuch es handelte sich auch nicht
um ein
Geheimtreffen sondern um eine private
Zusammenkunft die von diesen
korrektivaktivisten mit
Geheimdienstmethoden unter Missachtung
von
Persönlichkeitsrechten filtriert und
ausgespätt worden war um eine
Verschwörungstheorie gleich zu
Jahresbeginn zu
konstruieren die Position der
AFD und der AFD
Bundestagsfraktion zum Umgang mit der
millionenfachen irregulären und
illegalen Migration seit
2015 wird nicht in angeblichen
Geheimtreffen
festgelegt sondern auf Parteitagen und
in
Parteigremien das wissen sie
auch sie ist im Grundsatzprogramm von
2016 dargelegt im eu-wahlprogramm und in
zahlreichen Stellungnahmen sowie
parlamentsreden nachzulesen und zu
hören das erklärte Ziel der AFD
ist die Ausschöpfung aller
rechtsstaatlichen Mittel um illegale
Grenzübertritte zu verhindern durch
effektive
Grenzkontrollen nicht
aufenthaltsberechtigte Kriminelle und
Terrorverdächtige Migranten auszuweisen
und
abzuschieben
Einbürgerungen restriktiv zur
handhaben und missbräuchlich erlangte
staatsbürgerschaftten
abzuerkennen wer deutscher Staatsbürger
ist gehört ohne Frage ohne Zweifel zum
deutschen
Staatsvolk gerade deshalb darf die
deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft nicht verramscht
werden und mit der gießkanarne verteilt
werden und das sehr verehrte Damen und
Herren ist die Durchsetzung von
geltendem Recht und Gesetz das von
Regierungsseite seit jetzt fast einem
Jahrzehnt so sträflich vernachlässigt
wird
skandalös an diesem Vorgang von letzter
Woche ist das über den eigentlichen
Skandal geschwiegen wird es ist
skandalös wenn linke Aktivisten mit
Stasi ähnlichen Geheimdienst und
zersetzungsmethoden eine private
Zusammenkunft
angreifen um unbescholtene Bürger
abzuhören und
auszuspen es ist
skandalös wenn diese Aktivistengruppe
die unter dem Deckmantel der
journalistischen Recherche Auftritt von
staatlichen Stellen massiv mit
Steuergeldern finanziert wird es ist
skandalös wenn eine Mehrheit der
etablierten Medien die böswilligen
Fehlinterpretationen und unwahren
Behauptung dubioser Aktivisten ohne
Prüfung auf greift und
weiterverbreitet als handel es sich um
eine seriöse
Quelle es ist ein
Skandal wenn solche
Machenschaften für eine Kampagne
instrumentalisiert werden die das Ziel
verfolgt privaten Meinungsaustausch zu
kriminalisieren und unter
gesinnungskontrolle zu stellen um es mal
ganz deutlich zu sagen Alis Weide mit
ihrer Sicht der Dinge die sich in
Potzdam möglicherweise wiederholt
zugetragen haben wir